more than 50 years ago it all began here
on a small scale rich off debts nur says
it's hard to imagine today the German
businessman is very impressed by
Singapore
the city-state is now a modern and very
wealthy country and its citizens are
living longer and longer so how do
people live longer and remain healthy
that's the central question on debtless
mind as he heads out for a round of
interviews with scientists in the
high-tech metropolis first stop a visit
to a lab at the genome Institute
scientists here are cultivating stem
cells used to produce miniaturized
simplified versions of the human brain
clumps of gray matter just a little
larger than a grain of rice but with
huge potential
I can see the whole thing I guess and at
the round shape and the dimension of it
and it's crazy so called organoids are
paving the way to new discoveries in
healthcare we want to see how genetic
changes leads to a disease State
and we want to see how environmental
toxins sort of precipitate the disease
State
because once we can create all these
things in the laboratory we can think
about stopping the disease progressions
and and if we can do that it give us the
lead into how we can dance think about
developing therapeutics for talking's
and disease patients for example you
know it opened up tremendous
opportunities in how we can tackle human
diseases Parkinson's disease is still
incurable and until now research into it
focused on controversial animal
experiments it's difficult to carry out
research involving humans no one wants
to test things on their brain if they
don't know how it will turn out so
producing miniature brains allows you to
learn much faster that greatly improves
your chances of discovering a drug that
will really help fight Parkinson's
disease Desna is an internet
entrepreneur and he believes technology
will play a key role in making progress
but although that addition is thousands
of years old Chinese medicine still
plays a major role in healthcare in the
ultra-modern city
[Applause]
the government contacts from minutes
each by Megan's field I believe that in
the context of medicine we talked too
much about high-tech
gene manipulation and all those things
that are made possible by technology on
the other hand there's all this ancient
knowledge about healing like the use of
herbal medicine or just being there for
another person I mention how important
is the human relationship for healing a
patient how important is it for them to
have someone they can talk to someone to
contact
[Music]
an operating room at Singapore's
National University Hospital
I really respect doctors they have a
responsibility I wouldn't dare take on
it's one thing to build up a company and
take responsibility for it but here it's
really about life and death and new
methods to repair human beings
the dog basically print a replacement
part for a bone and implant it then this
bone part dissolves over the years and
the bone grows back replacing the
temporary prosthesis it's fascinating
it's fussing young osteo Paul a start-up
here is the company that developed this
technology a 3d printer creates bone
implants they're customized for each
individual which means even people with
very serious cases can be helped for
example when large areas of the skull
have been damaged
imagine you are an architect you build a
full tallest building when the building
architecture is finished you have to
remove the scaffold we remove the scar
for how do you remove it by D creating
it into carbon dioxide and water
so to build a great but the rate see
that the most important part over the
last 10 years we have found that we
stumble on a scaffold where the rate of
degradation is slow so that the cells
have time to girls brain tissue grown in
a petri dish bone implants from a 3d
printer debts no wonders how much longer
it will be before science can build a
human from the ground up I can grow body
parts
but not another human being because if
you don't draw the line then your mad
scientist a method this is the one that
has no limit but in scientists must have
limited you cannot do everything
especially you when you're near to
playing God
the scientists who work in fields like
these are driven to understand the
fundamental puzzle of life though most
know it's a puzzle that can't really be
solved freak off debts de thinks that's
exactly what makes research like this so
fascinating